fluffing this afternoon two people are
in critical condition after a shooting
in the east
valley metro police says this happened
during an attempted robbery on mountain
vista near hacienda
hector mejia is live at the scene right
now hector you have the latest on the
investigation good afternoon
good afternoon a victim and a robbery
suspect are now at the hospital fighting
for their lives after
a shooting at this apartment complex
this is 5400 vistas
we talked with homicide detectives here
on the scene earlier this morning and
they are the lead investigators
the victim and suspect both are said to
be in extremely critical condition
around 4 30 this morning police say the
victim was returning home from the gym
parking his car when he was approached
by two men
and what police say was an attempted
robbery at some point one suspect shot
into the car striking the victim
multiple times
when that same gunman ended up shooting
the other suspect he was with
the victim managed to drive off and dial
9-1-1 that brought police to the scene
and that's when they found both men with
gunshot wounds
and at this point they do not believe
the victim and the suspects knew each
other and it was not immediately clear
if police made any arrests here
however they are asking for the public's
help if you know anything about what
happened here earlier this morning
they're asking you to please give them a
call and you can remain anonymous
reporting in the east valley hector
mejia 8 news now